[Musica]
siamo pronti stiamo per fare una
sorpresa a iacopino non so se lo
ricordate lui quest'anno siamo formati
per tali scopi fa registrare un'altra
prova non ridere challenge del tipo
etico una poltrona per due è un
appuntamento natalizio non so quindi
torniamo a casa di jacopo commentato
abbiamo portato anche uno special guest
la casa jacopo ma il papa lo sa non ho
papa dicevo adesso andiamo a fare la
sorpresa jacopo che non sa chi sono e
allora e allora e allora è cresciuto un
sacco di quest'anno siamo come stargli
savino che abbracci gigantesco neanche
mia mamma mi ha preso così anzi 494 mio
anno al casinò
abbiamo portato i compiti via non
servono ti ho portato lui che lo portava
a casa direttamente è infatti spetta del
momento 04 come diceva di non dovevamo
ridere facciamo una trota ristabilite
ricordi come si chiamava questa è già la
prova non ridere no perché sto già
perdendo insomma è anche il cane ha
perso tra il termo testate in treno
madò che male che male madonna qualche
male questo è fatto ma lì si sentì lo
chef proprio la senti proprio come ha
fatto a distruggersi si è distrutto come
mi ha fatto ridere il bambino alla b era
già troppo della risata disordini vi si
è fatto malissimo
l'insegnante ci insegni come si vive e
questa la risposta si vive questo questo
video bellissimo avevo già tutto di nola
perso ma doc e archi tempismo
incredibile
che male una volta l'ho fatto anch'io a
scuola
[Musica]
è un film narra le indico di norvegia
no vabbè
questo era geniale era geniale
bellissimo si è appreso un bellissimo
[Musica]
dove che va a quella no ha già chi cade
anche io che me lo ricordo anch'io
spesso si cade o dio cosa è successo
queste cristiano questo è cristiano
guardano sotto sotto litro
questo è un fenomeno bravo così si fa ma
agiscono una coordinazione
[Musica]
ha mangiato la casa come che la torcia
umana è una specie di ma spaventato a
morte
[Musica]
pato come ha fatto yude perfette guarda
che roba
hai visti di per me no è generata non è
vero
no questo mai visto
vabbè allora secondo me ha vinto il cane
ha vinto il sun perché non ha riso si sa
ma non è questa e non sto giocando tra
noi due
tra noi due ovviamente io no siamo al
pareggio
siamo a fare il gioco conta lui spiega
vinto mare facciamo carta come capolista
non si gioca male che erano scorsi gioca
così e motta brava bene i bordi non so
quanto siamo parlo coi tuoi fan e non so
quanto siamo perché il conteggio lo
faccio in editing noi viene tengo tutti
a mente i punti quindi sapete voi chi ha
vinto però la divina commedia serbi
io vorrei concludere decretando il
vincitore e non riesco a farlo e questi
stanno ha parlato a un'ora e mezza
consigliavano di
carta forbice stesso cioè mese e mezzo
per di vista ho vinto e proprio tour
nipote si è sempre della stessa famiglia
si vede complimenti bra aiuti ha vinto
va bè ragazzi spero che vi sia piaciuto
e dai secolo che non facevamo una
profonda verità del genere facciamo
anche l'anno prossimo e che fino a
quando avrai trent'anni ragazzi fra i
cento
[Musica]